will be a combination of uh I guess
apologies and saying thank you so for
thank you for the organizers I should
say that's a that's a great Workshop
that you organize here and now I mean I
do start with an apology which is I'm
not as skillful in terms of Animation as
all the previous speakers I was going
through his playing simple ones
okay that's a interpretation but I'm
going to talk about it I'll say the
connection prescription obfuscation
minimization it's a joint work with
Valentin and Russell who I'm happy to
have here in the audience so in this
sort of the team of this Workshop it
talks about all kinds of assumptions and
bringing for cryptography I would like
to tilt the scale and look about this
from slightly different angle is
complexity theoretic what are the
necessary and sufficient complexity
theoretic assumptions for cryptography
right so you can actually take it too
many ways and there are all kinds of
things touched upon this in the previous
days as well but I would like to focus
on something very concrete here and this
is perhaps one of the Holy Grails of
complexity Reagan I don't have a Holy
Grail here but you'll have to forgive me
for that
and this is lower bounce so you know in
complexity you're improving lower bounds
is the Holy Grail but if I kind of want
to start this conversation as a
cryptographer the conversation ends
pretty fast because many standard
cryptographic assumptions already imply
strong lower bounds so basically if this
was it I had to live and you know say
goodbye the talk ended because you know
something very simple as one-way
functions once you say I have a one-way
function you already separated NP from
BPP and if it's a one-way point if you
secure against not uniform you know
adversaries you already separated MP
from P slash poly which is you know one
of those polygrills and it doesn't stop
here you can talk about
zero knowledge and all of that so all of
those things already give you strong
enough lower bounds so again if we want
to continue at least make sense in this
line we should ask the question do we
have any cryptographic Primitives that
do not know are not known to imply lower
bounds immediately and hint this
primitive should not imply on the
function which is is kind of restrictive
but I mean I'm going to ask the question
what is that it's on the title of the
talk what is an example of one of those
things that is not known to imply
one-way function but at the same time
it's not known to have lower bounds
anyone wants to guess you ask all the
questions so you want to guess right
oh that's a good answer
that's never for them yes so this is the
place when I want to sing Rachel for
introducing I also don't have to talk
too much about it but I do want to say a
few things so what is an io21 on the
Plainfield we want to take a program and
transfer into something which is
unintellable right so a few days ago
there was this conversation what should
problems look like some of you prefer
python so I'm a C plus plus person here
there's a C plus plus program what does
it do
for sure
well do they still pitch C plus plus and
the intro classes in my alma mater
IAL numbers
well congratulations you know you know
what it was called the Iowa experts
instantiation for the random Oracle
model right
is so equivalent but kind of more
broadly in this in terms of what we want
we want some kind of a procedure which
takes circuits transforms them into
another circuits with the property that
if you take to a circuit that have the
same size and functionality if you look
at their obfuscations their obfuscations
are indistinguishable basically you
cannot distinguish an electric one to
talk about more precisely in a minute
that's kind of this thing what we're
exploring and again thanks Rachel well
the great introduction and thanks for
that so let me talk a little bit more
about this so again this is the main
requirement that we want but the
question that I would like to ask is you
know what are the necessary you know the
question that we've been asking the
necessary insufficient permissions for
those things to exist but you know sort
of in particular we know that I all have
had a lot of applications for all kinds
of things cryptography and complexity as
one and at the same time for the past 15
years or so we saw numerous candidate
transactions culminating in GLS and now
again the real question is what are the
exact conditions so now when you look at
that from the complexity rate your
perspective and it was mentioned what
happens is that unlike the vast majority
of cryptographic Primitives you can
still get
I know even for something like P equals
MP in fact this is you know something
that you get in some Automotive way
right if P equals empty what you can do
is you can take a circuit you can learn
at an output the smallest canonical form
in that so this is again it doesn't
happen in memory function you don't have
that
so
this is already something which is
interesting and now that kind of brings
the question well where does IO live in
terms of that and to answer where we
live that there is no other place to
live then in place of five worlds so we
live in one of them so we could say that
we live somewhere again apologies are my
animations I cannot make those nice
animations that we had before but I'm
going to take it plain so the first one
is algorithmic so again this is what we
just discussed if basically P equals NP
orange because BPP will get the ultimate
composition so of course it exists it
can live nicely in algorithm what
happens if you go down the list so
heuristica is the place when NP hard
function we have empty hearts in the
worst case but it's easy on average in
particular we don't have one of the
functions so by combining some previous
results in particular L it's a good
reference if you have IO and one main
functions you basically get that MP is
an iobpp by the way that's not too
confused this small i o is infinitely
open this iOS of the station
doesn't exist
if you have i o when if you have if you
have IO okay if you have IO yes
we are not here yes if you have if you
have i o and you don't have basically if
you have i o and this doesn't happen you
have one function so basically you
cannot have that so in particular in
particular IO cannot live in heuristica
okay
for the exact same reason IO cannot live
in passing land because you don't have
one-way function so what's left going
down the rabbit hole mini Crypt so what
happens in many Crypt we do have one-way
functions but we don't have to say
public bibliography at the same time the
high and others have shown that if we
have iom on the function you can
actually get public photography which
kind of means that you don't get IO
either in many quick what's left what's
left is where I think if I ask most of
you you're all going to save and live
there we live in crypto Mania so
cryptomanias where cryptography it's
possible we have one function public
encryptions all the nice things and the
recent work the great work of Rachel and
colleagues make it a great argument that
I only exist so I'm going to apologize
for you Rachel because I'm only going to
put it in yellow because it's still
under assumption here and here it's not
but here it's under assumption so you're
going to forgive me so in conclusion
what do we have we have that I O can
only exists in algorithmic and
cryptomania although there is this new
trend to try to would Define the new
sixth World which is called office
catopia or something like that but okay
in the spread in between these two and
the main issue here is that
the assumptions for Io and until they
all to wrap around so that we want as a
community as in cryptography to live in
crypto media but if you're not careful
enough you may end up very well go go
and find yourself in algorithmic this is
kind of what makes I think I oh no
trivia questions
yes but if you just say your IO is
computational then it's definitely
cryptomania
right because algorithmic IO is
statistical
well I mean if it's statistical it's
also computational right I mean it's a
stronger you get the Ultimate Team i o
here which in particular is
computational right it's a strictly
conversation it's not well it's not
clear how you make well
how do we make something you know
computational and not you kind of have
to be precise about that right
but other than that this one is also
computational that you get here good
more questions
[Music]
so man this is not again the only object
as you said but this is one of a few
objects that kind of share the property
of course right good yes so actually let
me switch gears and talk about something
else which is a little bit outside of
the realm of what people traditionally
do in um
in cryptography but it's still very very
relevant and this is the minimum circuit
size problem so we heard a few talks on
the topic and actually I would this is
the place to say to thank honey for
giving great introduction about this
topic so I don't have to talk too much
about it but I still want to say a few
things so what's the problem here we're
given a true stable a string of lengths
two to the n and they give a size the
parameter and what we'd like to know
whether there is a circuit of size s
that implements the suitable
so this important thing to emphasize
here is that your input size is not n
but 2 to the end this is kind of a
typical usually n is the input size so
just to realize that this already gives
us something relatively straightforward
which is that mcsp is an empty right
so why is it in NP because first of all
you can guess the circuit then you can
do is check that the circuit actually
computes this through stable again we
can be in efficient and two to the end
so this is the thing that we know and
this is unfortunately one of the few
things we actually know because all the
other things are start getting
convoluted so one important property
about that mcsp nonetheless is that it's
not a bug that's a picture so uh work a
line of work started biology children's
Borrowed by and subsequent work pretty
much showed that any one-way function
can be involved inverted by btpl which
was an mcsp worker right so I mean this
is since it's a cryptographic audience
so we should correct myself instead of
BPP I should say pptm but you can pardon
my franchising right
I'm not one previous because it was
already
so the point is if I have a randomized
algorithm with an MCS purical I can
invert all those I can compute solve all
those nice problems like individual
factor to Nifty Helm and lettuce
problems and FCP you know what FCP is
it's your favorite typographic problem
Oracle
I'm trying to cycle back there are some
nice connections here so this you know
may give some ideas that mcsp is maybe
way too powerful maybe it's even NP
complete so that's one of the questions
what is the exact complexity of mcsp
right so okay in the first thought was
let's try and see whether it's going to
complete so this is a place where you
have to say thank you to Ryan and other
people who've shown that if mcsp is
actually going to be completing the
standard sense what we get is X not
equal GDP so sort of again to understand
this properly While most of us do
believe that X is equal to CPP our
current techniques are far away from
establishing that so the conclusion is
that even if we believe that mcsp is
going to be hard it will take us some
kind of non-trivial techniques a
non-trivial breakthroughs we actually
shown something like that so based on
that there was sort of a suggestion that
we should perhaps look at three mcsp is
an NP intermediate problem those
probability between and in fact there
are great things to support it results
by Alan Duran does that show that you
can solve glyphosomorphism in fact SDK
the class of problems that we all like
and have all those nice cryptographic
problems we can solve that ISP
so that's nice but the question kinda
remains okay maybe mcsp is still hard
but maybe other broad donut Maybe
you don't have to expand your reduction
AC repair reduction the DVP reduction
maybe uh useless for the reduction
that's the conjecture that perhaps okay
if we can't achieve the usual you know
reduction maybe we have to broaden the
reduction then we can show hardness of
mcsp this is a conjecture and now sort
of to type back to i o there's a throws
out of interesting connection there was
observed previously in a different
context in the paper by Common Goods
one-way function which is the following
connection suppose IO exists then mcsp
is in BPP if and only if NP is in DPP
sort of uh this has this flavor of
completeness right if I have I O then
mcsp this problem varies the whole
weight of this MP plus it's not sort of
the last the best thing that we want but
this already gives us the flavor that
connects things together
so just maybe to wrap it up if so to
wrap yourself around there to be free
intuition mcsp and DPP it's kind of
morally equivalent there is no one-way
function you want to think about it this
way there are some gaps here but sort of
this is the moral thought
so
I do want to say two more words about IO
before I give you the results questions
about that
yeah I'm not going to introduce IO from
scratch but I do want to make a few sort
of specifications in terms of what do we
want from and I also the main properties
that we want is one correctness and
actually I want to talk about more
broadly so usually when you talk about
IO when we obfuscate it you want the
obfuscated circuit to have the same
functionality this is what's called a
perfect obfuscater but you can also look
at what's called an imperfect obfuscator
absolutely perfect what does it mean it
means that well you're going to get what
you want with high probability so
basically it's Mobility one minus
Epsilon the open scale itself it has the
same the same functionality but the
probability absolutely you can get all
kinds of garbage Etc so for example if
Epsilon is f zero it's a perfect value
so this is useful and now one more thing
which is sort of the other requirement
of an i o is what's called security so
you want to Define it broadly so what is
security against a class of algorithm so
imagine that a is a class of algorithms
so security means the usual thing if you
take two circuits which have the same
size and the same functionality then
they're indistinguishable okay this
whole crazy thing means that in
distribution or the distinguishing
probability is something like Delta so
typically we want Delta to be small
negligible but as we will see then I
deliberately put your Delta it doesn't
have to be there's a certain trade
between absolute Delta for which we can
still work so now why do we want to look
at the class of algorithms the two
typical scenarios are when a is taking
to be all the efficient algorithms this
is what corresponds to computationally
secure i o or sort of the high end of it
which is a is the class of all
algorithms very inefficient doubly
equally exponential in this case this is
the class of statistically oil so the
reason I want to talk about security for
a cloud because I'm actually going to
look at something sort of in between
something which is between this BPP and
everything
questions about the definitions so again
what we should be thinking about when I
say imperfect and secure is that sort of
the extreme case the usual thing is
Epsilon and Delta being negligible but
you can still think about them being
constant there is a trade division I'm
going to mention think about Epsilon
being small and Delta being small is
still going to work
so now I can actually tell you what the
results are the the connections between
IO and mcsp and hopefully answer some of
the questions here
so let me start and the first flavor of
result that we show is lower balls from
IO namely if you have IO you got lower
ball that would be more specific here so
the first set of results is suppose you
have a perfect IO which is secure
against business policy secure against
non-uniform adversaries so you get that
next the photography slash poly and you
also get basically super polynomial
lower balance for next and you also get
what's called fixed polynomial lower
bounds or NP you cannot compute MP by
circuits of size n to Decay for any k
this is what happens if you have
a perfect tail now if you have an
imperfect IO you get something weaker so
you get super polynomial low bounds
against MH
that's fixed polynomial or balance
against Ma
so yes for context
because I'm going to repeat it next is
the exponential version of NP
okay discuss this a little bit and
neglect with your questions so as far as
we know this is the first
the first consequence of strong lower
bounds from existence of IO
and if you know something else please
let me know to be curious and now we
want to compare it to what we know kinda
unconditionally so unconditionally
without any assumptions we have lower
bounds for mih what is Mia to the
exponential version of a and next is the
exponential version of NP and X is the
exponential version of Ama
and we also have for the low regime we
have
bounds fixed polynomial bounds for m a
slash one this is thanks to Rahul
and now one thing I'll let you know if
you kind of look at this ma in the
message one it might seem a really small
thing this is really one bit of advice
but I'll tell you that you wouldn't
believe how much time the community
spent on removing this one bit of advice
like you wouldn't believe it
so I mean you can think about it well
maybe I always a big big big a big thing
to assume but IO allows you to do that
in particularly we're talking about all
kinds of applications so one of the
applications is to remove one bit of
advantage
and hopefully there are better ways to
do it but you know at least that
and the other thing that I want to
mention that while all those bounds and
others on this slide again they believe
them to hold unconditionally sort of we
believe that next is not in business
bully and everything we believe it to
behold unconditionally the State of
Affairs is kind of said because it looks
like we're nowhere near proving any of
this violence including this bit of
advice we're nowhere near to doing it
unconditionally and if you actually want
to read more about it I would like to
say Brian for writing that good a good
survey about that sort of what's the
problems here
questions yes you get more mileage if
you have some explanation security for
that yeah so right so we did uh we
didn't actually look I mean I suspect
you can get some kind of a parametrics
you I suspect you can get more but you
can actually look at to this I suspect
you can do more I mean I was gay I would
say yes but we didn't actually look at
that to formally
more questions Marco
is
the uniformed versions
one more slide to tell you what happens
then very good yes you know
so if you ask yourself what's the lowest
in terms of what's the lowest class for
which you know super polynomials Mis
so I mean I can unconditioned to
original
then we have i o
so doesn't that complicated
unless you get stronger lower bounds if
you assume
yeah
you get those kinds of lower bounds for
p itself already you get the B is open
size
just
no questions
so this is again if you assume secure
insecure perfect it's imperfect okay if
you assume perfect for imperfect IO
which is secure against non-uniform
adversaries and the next thing is what
happens as per Marco's question what
happens if you assume security against
uniform so this is kinda
the next thing that I want to talk to
you suppose now you have i o which is
perfect and secure against the sort of
uniform advertise right so you get a
couple of things so one thing which I
mean I find surprising but the Valentin
actually decided that it was in it it
was decided that
it's uh worth mentioning I actually
found it surprising and you mentioned
that is that the following if you have
such an i o that if mcsps and BPP you
get that np's and GTP sort of think
about that you start with a problem in
mp it's some DPP then the whole class
collapses down to zpp
I know that the people in crypto if you
don't care much about the difference
with BPP and CPP but just appreciate it
right so
[Laughter]
so now the interesting thing is that
again the maybe the next bullet will
help you appreciate it better is that
well we can actually use this result to
show something else you can use the
result to separate zpx from VPP so zpx
is the exponential version of BPP
so
that let me again questions about the
results that we discussed that in the
broader context so basically what do we
know here so uh unfortunately so we have
those hierarchy theorems for space and
time unfortunately if I don't have those
theorems for randomized complexity class
we don't have what's called for
simulating classes but nonetheless if
you want to separate zpp from zps
basically this is the exponential
version this is something which is
relatively easy to do now if you kind of
start turning the hip a little bit we
don't know to separate next from VPP or
more even so x to the MP from DP this is
the middle class super class so we don't
know how to do that we don't know how to
separate neck MPP and even more so we
don't know how to separate zipx is a
subclass of x
probably something often problems which
are kind of lying around
and what we show is that if you assume
that we have computation in Secure i o
then you get those separation we get
basically this one
so this is again another application
this is better than one bit of advice I
think this is I think it's been lying on
the street for much longer time
there is perhaps one reason why it's
been so hard
there are there is an oracle under which
all those classes basically BPP next one
all of that every single trying to
separate that all those classes are kind
they're equal and if you kind of plug it
back what you get is you don't get
something to do much I think it's
interesting to get that relative to that
Oracle oh we don't have an i o
so that's not the new result of course
you're going to tell me that you know
pick any pestilian Oracle or something
like you wouldn't have an IO other but I
think it's a nice connection so you can
exclude IO by looking at Oracle which
sort of collapses some complexity
classes and kind of brings me to the
next point something was discussing
earlier I don't know the answer to this
question maybe you do
uh what happens with a random Oracle so
do we have I always regard with respect
to random work so if for example you
prove that those things are equal to
this with respect to random Oracle you
show that you don't have an IO with
respect to render mode not sure if
that's the best way to do it but I think
it's a nice
100 defined I always random Oracle like
but that's the office Canton circuit has
access to animals
so your circuit is an oracle circuit
basically right and your output circuit
is an oracle circuit pretty much
everybody has an Arab has an oracle can
access over right
okay it's good because what I do want to
do is I want to give you a little bit of
a flavor here but I do want to talk
about the last point and this is sort of
the other direction how mcsp can Empower
it all sort of the thing that fuels this
whole uh all those results is the
following connection and I always
statistically secure any i o if and only
if it's secure against difficult this is
the reason if you think about PVP today
CSP it's well it's a super class
syntactic superclass of BPP and of
course it's a subclass of all the
possible algorithms but as it turns out
is that statistical means it's secure
for any possible algorithm but it
actually means that if you want your
best distinguisher the distinguisher
doesn't have to live high high in the
sky like I don't know X space or
something like that it lives sort of
relatively down on Earth in DPP to the
mcsp
so this
support fuels it and
sort of as some conclusion you can also
extend the result that we had for
imperfect angle so if you have an
imperfect IO then the same thing holds
through mcsps and BPP if and only if MPS
the biggest we know how to do it for
perfect
it's extended to improved
so a few remarks here that I would like
to point out so we talked about IO and
all of those results we kinda assume
that I always have my own for all
circles but as it turns out you don't
need to get those results you don't need
and I offer all circuits you can it's
enough to have I offer much much much
smaller circuits like three cnfs and all
you need is the circuit class from which
the equivalence problem is going to be
hard and as adults out these are much
much smaller for example three cnfs or
bit wise but I think the surprising
thing is that it's enough to consider
monotone class if you consider monotone
depth reformulas again monotone is out
no if you can obfuscate monotone that's
three formulas you already get all those
results again you get the exact same
results for any of those classes so let
me just mentioned that all those classes
are much much smaller typically as we
heard what happens is that all all the
existing candidate constructions kinda
start from nc1 you go to MC1 in their
new Boost so all those classes are much
much smaller than nc1 that's already
enough to get those Balance all all the
things that I talked about
oh no okay
so yes I mean not like okay so I didn't
hear what the last one sorry so yes so
basically this is what it is so
I mean you're doing it you're doing it
the security you don't need the security
right you don't need the security thing
that says okay if it's uh if it has the
same functionality it has it has to be
the same right it's not you get the
security you're not going to obfuscate
everything but you don't need the
security requirement right
that sounds
no questions
and let me just mention in terms of
Epsilon Delta remember this security and
imperfect imperfection so you don't have
to be com you don't have to be perfect
you don't have to be negligible it's
enough that your security is less than
one minus Epsilon Square when Epsilon is
the level of imperfection right so
basically you can have an input slightly
imperfect uh i o which is somewhat
somewhat secure and it's still all going
to afford all these things are going to
work
questions concerns complaints
so I would like to maybe give you one
days but this is another place when I do
want to say my one last thank you as I
learned recently literally a few days
ago from talking to money and guy that
you can actually extract that result if
you dig up a little bit into one of
their proofs you can actually extract
that result you didn't think about in
the context of mcsp but if you take your
result a piece of your result extracted
to put mcsp on top of it you can
actually recreate that so thank you for
that
now let me just maybe give you one
flavor of one of the proofs of one of
the flow mounts and it will and it will
be the thing I like to kind of start by
proving something very very weak and
this is the following suppose you have
imperfect statistical as a qio now I
want to show that am doesn't have six
polynomial size circuits okay how do I
do that
so the the starting point goes back to a
fundamental I think first result that
kind of started exploring those
impossibility results for Io and this is
the result of thanks guys thanks Shafi
goldbuster Road Bloom that pretty much
showed that if you have imperfect
statistically secure oh then the
polynomial hierarchy collapses to am
this was the result among other things
they've shown that
and now how do you get from this to this
is an easy exercise and diagonalization
what you show is that polynomial
hierarchy does not have circuits of size
n to the end of the K right this is a
standard diagonalization that we do so
how do we put the two together well if
you have statistically the qio pH
collapses to a m For Better Or forwards
which means that now am doesn't have
those circuits either this is how you
get that
yeah so let's conclude what we have so
far that if we have statistically say
qio that am doesn't have circus but this
given gold Master this result is not
surprising anyone specifically after
their work nobody I think believes in
statistically secure IO it's like it
would have written here uh this is true
if Health rolls or this is true if
there's snow in California right this is
kinda you know all those kind of
statements this is what it looks like so
let's move a little bit to something
slightly more important slightly more
interesting than that is again let's
plug in our result it says we have
statistical security if we only have
security against bbp to mgnsp right so
if you plug it you can just substitute
statistical with stat security and what
you get is that something slightly
interesting if you have an imperfect IO
which is secure against DVP to the mcs3
then we have lower balance against am
so this may be slightly more interesting
and now to put the fine thing here I
want to actually go from this to our
result which is if I have an i o which
is secure against key slash polish I get
lower bounds I want to go from this to
this and this is done by the standard
two-pronged approach we're using
complexity Theory also known as the
movement argument and the interesting
thing is that it's conditioned on the
complexity of mcsp namely two cases if
mcsp is not confused poly we're already
done because mcsp is an NP which is an
am so we're done am is not in business
poly the other thing is more interesting
what happens if mcsb isn't business poly
and he says something interesting
happens I think
to do that now let's just take 30
seconds and read what it says on the
slide right shall we what does what is
it that we're trying to do we're trying
to say that if team perfect IO is secure
against P slash poly then
then am has lower bounds but what did we
have now under this assumption mcsp is
in BPP and DPP to the ncsp is poly which
means that if you're secure against PS4
you're in particular secure against the
people to the mcsp but it's a subset of
that
and now we're going back to the Quarry
which says exactly that if you're secure
against BPP to the mcs3 have low amounts
and now that's the place where you
combine and say look they have two cases
either in not in P slash poly or here
which means that either way you're not
in a you're not in size n to decay
okay let me just finish one but Lamar
can say that if you want to get it if
you want it in the perfect case you have
to use another observation that pretty
much says that if you secure against the
perfect that you're secure against this
PVP to the LCS feed the polynomial
hierarchy collapses all the way to entry
not just am PNP this is how you get NP
in the case of perfect security so
actually a good time to stop and let me
summarize what we've shown is that
imperfect or perfect i o secure against
non-uniform circuits in non-uniform
circuits imply non-trivial or bounds and
sort of there are a few interesting
questions in particular what Mark was
can we derived lower bounds if we assume
security against uniform
attackers and sort of the other thing
which I think is um sort of a way to
interpret this results right if you go
back maybe
if we go just let me go back here and
you know go back and sort of think about
uh like here how should we interpret
those lower bound results so you know
those little bows are hard so one way to
interrupt would be to say
life is hard complexity is complicated
cryptography is even more complicated so
let's do something practical like
machine learning that's one way to
interpret those results
I think a better way would be to say
whenever we construct propose new
candidate iOS we should be conscious
right they should be conscious that
whatever we're going to do we're talking
about eliminating assumptions right
whatever we're going to do we should be
conscious that if we eliminate too many
assumptions we're actually going to hit
the slower bound barrier so we have to
be conscious about that and this is sort
of the sort of the takeaway that
I think is thing here is that I have
discovered the truly marvelous proof of
this lower bounds which this candidate
IO construction the two unconscious to
contain right so when you think about
constructing a candidate IO you
typically don't think about blowing
lower bowels but that's the thing once
you do that apparently you do one and do
the other right so this is this thing
that I wanted the message I wanted to
say and there are other problems which
are sort of uh related which I'm just
going to write it down and I'm going to
talk about in the interest of time so
thank you
thank Celia for any great old school
talk and yeah
and stay right here we have now
[Music]
assumptions in photography complexity
Theory thank you